[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAMIEN HENRY: --to upload
their content online
and to tell stories about them.
There is more than 2,000
museums on the platform now.
And we have a lab,
and The Lab is
where we explore interaction
between the art culture
and technology.
For instance, it's the place
where David Coz and I started
the cardboard.
It's a virtual set
made out of cardboard.
It's also the place where
we started ArtSelfie,
this feature that
allows you to find
if there is a portrait in a
museum that looks like you.
It's super fun.
If you haven't
tried, you should.
And we are doing
many other stuff.
You can check them from
G.co/artsexperiment.
What is really
exciting with The Lab
is that we have a program
named Artists in Residency.
So we have the opportunity to
work directly with artists.
And for this
specific project, we
asked the Somerset
House, which is
an institution based in London,
to help us to curate an artist.
And the open call that
they made for that
was named End Dimensions.
So they select Jenna Sutela.
Jenna Sutela is a
woman, an artist
working with words, with
audio, and with living
materials and technology.
And her work has been presented
at the Bilbao Guggenheim
and also in the Contemporary
Art Museum of Tokyo.
And for this project, we asked
Memo Akten, a very influential
creative curator to help
Jenna realize her vision.
So what you will see now
is a 12-minute video,
so it's a [? video ?]
of her work.
But just before
that, we would like
to roll a five-minute
video behind the scene
so you will have more
context about why
she does what she does.
So first I'll just roll
the behind the scene.
I hope you enjoy it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WARBLED VOICES SPEAKING IN
TONGUES]
- nimiia cetii is an audiovisual
artwork based on machine
learning or teaching the
machine to speak in tongues.
So my name is Jenna
Sutela, and I work a lot
with words, sounds,
and living materials
exploring biological and
computational systems.
I'm working with
machine learning
to generate a certain
type of glosa poetry based
on the Martian language by
the French medium Helene Smith
in the late 1800s and the
movement of Bacillus subtilis,
or the natto bacterium
that are also
known as a test species in
spaceflight experimentation.
Together, the bacteria, as well
as these early Martian scripts,
will--
together with the
computer shaman
will create a new
language altogether,
and the end result will
be an audiovisual work.
[WARPED SOUNDS]
nimiia cetii is something
that I worked on
as part of my residency at
the Somerset House Studios
and at the Google
Arts and Culture Lab
in Paris together with
Mem Akten and Damien Henry
from Google Arts
and Culture Lab.
- So I've been working
with computer vision
for well over a decade now,
trying to get machines to see.
But in the last
four or five years,
I've also been very interested
in machine learning, which
has actually in the last couple
of years really exploded.
Really using more
state-of-the-art machine
learning is really
conceptually fascinating
because at the heart of a
lot of these state-of-the-art
algorithms, it parallels a lot
of cognitive processes that we
might have in our own brains
in the sense that we need
to distill these different
mediums down to common abstract
representations.
And that's what the machine
learning approach has.
- So Bacillus subtilis
is the main ingredient
of natto, or fermented
soybeans, known
as a very healthy probiotic.
Bacillus subtilis is one
of the main bacteria taken
to space on, for example,
the Mars missions
to test the limits of life.
This bacteria that it
can also survive on Mars
and maybe it also
came from Mars and is
this alien that we
inhabit through the food
that we're eating
like the probiotics.
So it's the kind of
protagonist of this project.
And right now, I'm
using its movement
as a script for this
language that is generated.
So the bacteria is filmed
through a microscope,
and then the movement
of the bacteria
is observed by the computer.
- We look at the video,
and we somehow encode that
to high-dimensional
latent space,
which we think of as a language
agnostic representation of what
this system--
in this case, the bowl of
bacteria-- is thinking.
And from that we
decode into text.
We decode into a kind of
what we call the handwriting.
We decode into speech.
[WARBLED VOICES]
- The idea was to generate
language that's audible,
and that's the part
that we've been
working with Damien in Paris.
So the idea is basically to
record these snippets of sound
and then feed these
into the computer
and have it learn that voice.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- It's very important for
us to work with artists
because it's the opportunity to
use algorithm in a way that's
not been designed in full.
- The processes that take
place in machine learning
are also largely unknown to us.
So there's the idea
of the black box,
and it's not clear
what exactly is
happening when the computer
is learning something.
So we're also sort
of-- we created
an alien in that respect.
There's a lot of
similarities between looking
into the microscope and
looking into the cosmos.
I think we're all
on board, or we
can know what needs to be done.
This residency has been a lot
about learning about machine
learning in practice
and also about what's
interesting in that territory.
[TAPPING]
[WARPED SOUNDS]
[END PLAYBACK]
DAMIEN HENRY: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
So this was just a
teaser, of course,
so now let's roll the video.
It's 12 minutes long.
Thanks.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WARPED SOUNDS]
[WARBLED VOICES SPEAKING IN
TONGUES]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[WARBLED VOICES SPEAKING IN
TONGUES]